- [Instructor] Anatomically
modern human beings
have been on this planet
for roughly 200,000 years.
And even though that's a small fraction
of the amount of time the
Earth has been around,
which is over 4 billion years,
on a human scale it's an
incredibly long amount of time.
Just to put it in perspective,
if this is present time,
if you wanted to put,
when was the Roman Empire?
Well, if we're talking
about 2000 years ago,
it would show up on our
timeline right about there.
If you wanted to talk about
when the pyramids were constructed,
it would be right about there.
You could hardly see the time difference
between now and several
thousand years ago.
If you want to see how
long we've had writing,
about 5000 years is our
current best estimate.
Once again, it barely
shows up on this timeline.
How long have we had agriculture?
Well, 10 to 15 thousand years.
Once again, it's a small fraction of this.
Another way to think about it,
think about all of our ancestors,
the various generations that have passed
since the first appearance
of anatomically modern human beings.
This is over 6 or 7 thousand
generations into the past.
Think about all of the stories
that must have happened.
A lot of simple things.
It might be a founding of a village,
a killing of an animal,
a very simple courtship,
a tenderness between a
mother and their child.
And think about the big things,
the wars, the battles,
the natural disasters.
It's hard for us to imagine
how much has occurred
even in the last hundred or
two hundred or thousand years,
much less 200,000 years.
But we seek to understand regardless.
And that is what history is all about.
And as we'll see, history is in general
trying to understand
the stories of our past.
And if we want to get a
little bit more technical,
we can also think about
prehistory, which is, technically,
the things that happened
before we had writing.
Because writing is our
main tool for history.
What I have right over here, this picture,
this is Egyptian hieroglyphs.
And Egyptian hieroglyphs
are over 5000 years old.
I could write 5000
years before the present.
But even when you have
writing, it's not enough
as we'll see not only in this video,
but in many videos as we study
history and world history.
It's really a lot of science
and a lot of detective work
to make sense of what has happened.
And that understanding
will constantly evolve.
For example, we didn't know
what these hieroglyphs said
until 1799 when we
found the Rosetta Stone.
And what was useful
about the Rosetta Stone
is that they had some text
written in the hieroglyphs
and they had the same text
then written in a Greek
that we were able to understand
and that started to help unlock
what these hieroglyphs said.
But even once you have
a sense of what they say
or even if you understand it quite well,
you still have to do a
lot of detective work
and take everything with a grain of salt.
You can imagine
if there's a bunch of
groups of people here
and we get the history from this group,
for some reason we were able
to find what they wrote,
well it might not be completely unbiased.
They might have a negative view
of this group or that group.
And so you have to take it
all with a grain of salt.
At the extreme form, they
might have eliminated
some of these groups and
then only they were around
to say what actually happened.
You also have to be skeptical
because you don't know
whether these stories are actual accounts
or whether someone just made
it up to fit a worldview.
You also have to keep in
mind that these stories,
whether they were transmitted
written or orally,
they're oftentimes retransmitted
from generation to generation,
and especially in the oral case.
But even in the written,
you've gotta wonder
what's added over each generation.
You can imagine people embellishing,
making the story a little bit better.
Or taking out things of the story
that really doesn't fit
in with their worldview.
So even when we have the writing,
and this is once again, some
images of early writing.
This is the famous Sumerian
cuneiform tablet here.
Even when we have it, obviously,
we have much much more writing
as we get to the more recent past,
we have to be very very very skeptical.
We know, today,
even if two observers
observed something yesterday,
something that just
happened, they might have
very very different
perceptions of what happened.
So even though there's writing,
we have to be skeptical.
But things get, in some
ways, even more interesting
before we have writing,
when we go into prehistory.
You might wonder how do we know
anything about what happened
if there's no written accounts?
Well that's where the science
and we get even more detective work.
For example, this is a Neanderthal skull.
And the type of people, the
sciences that will study this,
you'll hear terms like anthropologists.
Anthropologists or anthropology.
This is the study of
present and past humans
and human society.
And then a subset of anthropology,
which is really delving into prehistory
and even history itself, is archaeology.
Archaeology which is the
subset of anthropology
that focuses on the past study
of humans and human society
and they're mainly going
to do it through remains.
Now there's other fields,
you might associate,
the field of paleontologist.
Paleontologist.
Paleontology.
You might associate this with
things like dinosaur bones,
but their techniques are also
useful for old human remains
or even pre-human remains.
And so it might inform
archaeology and anthropology.
So for example, an archaeologist
might unearth this Neanderthal skull.
They will use some science
in order to figure out:
When did this skull enter into the ground?
They might use a technique
like radiocarbon dating.
Radiocarbon dating,
which could be used for things
up to around 50,000 years old,
so around that time span on our timeline.
And it's based on this idea
that you have this atmospheric carbon-14
that actually comes from nitrogen-14
that gets between interactions
with the solar wind
and these cosmic particles
becomes this radioactive carbon-14.
And the carbon-14 which can
become part of carbon dioxide
incorporate into plants
through photosynthesis
which then get eaten into animals.
So while something is living,
they'll have a certain amount
of carbon-14 in their tissue.
But then once they die,
they're now no longer
adding more carbon-14.
And the carbon-14 decays into
the more stable carbon-12.
And so based on the ratio
between the carbon-14 to the carbon-12,
and it takes roughly 5,000
years, 5,730 years to be exact,
for roughly half of the carbon-14 to decay into carbon-12.
So based on this ratio,
and I go into much more
detail in other videos,
you can figure out how
old these things are
and you get reasonably precise,
within a couple of a
hundred, hundreds of years.
If you want to go further into the past,
there's things like
potassium-argon dating,
which is once again taking a
radioactive form of potassium
and using the idea that
it decays into argon.
And that when a volcano
releases the argon in that rock,
is able to go into the atmosphere,
but then once it hardens,
you have the decay and so you can see
how long since that volcanic
eruption are we looking at.
And so for example, you can dig,
you can do stratographic
techniques right over here.
Stratigraphy, I have
trouble saying these words.
That's looking at the
various layers of the earth.
And you might use some dating techniques,
for example potassium-argon.
Say: "Okay, this is that,
a certain amount of age,
"that is a certain amount of age,
"this was volcanic rock
from a volcanic eruption."
And then you can look at the fossils.
You can say: "Okay, a
fossil that I found here"
"is going to be newer than the stuff here"
"and it's gonna be older
than the stuff here"
"and this might be the newest of all."
So you can look at relative dating
and if you're lucky enough
to have some volcanic rock,
you could do some of this
potassium-argon dating
and there's many many
many other techniques.
And it isn't just about
saying: "Oh, this skull
"was in this place in
the world at this time."
You can start to infer other things.
You can look for fossils
of the type of animals,
the type of plants near
these burial sites.
You could see how dense
these burial sites were,
what type of cultures were there.
You could start to make inferences.
You can try to infer
how these people died.
You might have some trauma fractures here
and you might say: "Okay,
that was a violent death."
You might look at their
teeth to think about the type
of things they might have
eaten or their general health.
You might look at the tools
that are buried near them.
This right over here, these
are Paleolithic arrow,
I guess, spearheads or
tools right over here.
Paleolithic is defined by
more of these harder edges.
You have Neolithic tools
which have more of these smoother edges.
Then Old Stone Age, New
Stone Age right over here.
And by looking at all of that,
you have all of these
scientists, you have these
anthropologists,
archaeologists, paleontologists,
who are starting to piece
together prehistory.
And sometimes these
techniques are done together.
Sometimes we have writing
and we have these technique
to try to get a more complete picture.
Now I want to end with
just a note of caution.
Even though we have all
of these techniques,
we're learning more
everyday, our understanding
of all that has happened
is very very incomplete.
And even more, it
constantly gets challenged
the more we learn.
There are things that very
serious people believed
50 or 100 years ago that we
have now proven to be false.
And things that we now
take very seriously,
it's likely that in 50 or 100 years
people might prove some of that wrong.
So history, even though
it's about the past,
it is constantly evolving.
We're constantly learning more
and we should have a very solid humility
about what we know and what we don't know.